las manifestaciones en colombia empiezan
a preocupar tanto a los productores de
alimentos como a los consumidores los
efectos en la seguridad alimentaria de
la ciudad de bogotá después de 10 días
de paro y bloqueos en carreteras lo
empiezan a sentir los distribuidores de
frutas verduras y otros alimentos
corabastos una de las mayores plazas
mayoristas en la capital dijo en twitter
son bastantes inestables los precios de
alimentos en el mercado mayorista de la
capital del país por abastos en las
últimas horas continúan llegando
vehículos con productos a deshoras los
precios que se registran actualmente son
atípicos por las variaciones altas al
consumidor ante el temor de quedarse con
las estanterías vacías el director de
economía rural y abastecimiento se
pronunció el mensaje contundente es que
si hay comida
los campesinos están listos para cargar
tenemos mucha comida represada en los
cierres de lo que necesitamos que dejen
pasar el mensaje de tranquilidad porque
si hay comida necesitamos habilitar los
corredores humanitarios para clientes
durante las protestas el uso excesivo de
la fuerza por parte de las autoridades a
la armada de organizaciones no
gubernamentales y también al secretario
general de la organización de los
estados americanos quien condenó los
actos de violencia y las torturas al
tiempo que pidió el fin de los bloqueos
el derecho a la protesta no puede ser un
pretexto para vulnerar los derechos
fundamentales de la población como la
salud como el trabajo como la educación
como la libre circulación en ese sentido
se exhorta al sence los bloqueos cuando
violan estos derechos fundamentales de
la gente y respalda la más amplia paz
social en el marco de las
reivindicaciones que se quieran hacer el
gobierno colombiano que busca encontrar
consensos con distintos sectores
políticos económicos y sociales también
exigió el fin de los bloqueos las
protestas que comenzaron contra la ya
retirada reforma tributaria continúan
ahora contra un intento de reformar la
salud contra la brutalidad policial y la
compleja situación de inseguridad